je vous ai gardé pour la fin de cette
émission mireille parce que parce que
vous êtes assez gai je trouve que votre
livre de souvenirs avec le soleil pour
témoin ressemble tout à fait à votre
musique c'est dire que c'est un c'est un
livre gay enjouée qui est délicieux qui
est à la fois plein de charme et de
nostalgie et puis quand le drame parce
que tout le monde vous avez venus
certains draps quand le drame arrive
dans votre vie bien pour passer très
vite parce que vous avez beaucoup de
pudeur alors et moi je suis évidemment
je connais vos chansons que j'ai
beaucoup comme la plupart des français
je savais que vous étiez marié à ce
grand écrivain qui emmanuel berl puisse
à peu près tout ce que je savais donc
évidemment le petit conservatoire de
musique mais j'ignorais complètement que
vous avez été communiquée ce biais jouer
à pour au bout et à hollywood josa et
que j'ai tourné avec master in win 7
janvier face à ce tir qui tenait pas du
tout humala je suis très signeront un de
ces choses là mais bon bein ces deux
sont des sujets xavier lâche on avait
tourné avec buster keaton
ça
ne me demandez pas mon âge vous le dire
est maintenant
c'est fini
mais je sais pas je vais je trouvais que
l'avis de diabète de miribel été très
très mouvementée et
je pense est un petit peu à la bienvenue
physique elle avait été très mouvementée
aussi très bon
je crois que ça a commencé très tôt j'ai
été
vous savez j'étais régie je le suis
toujours d'abord si je suis là c'est
parce qu un lutin vous a soufflé à
l'oreille probablement où vous a montré
livre je sais rien moi même je ne sais
pas
parler des gangs à
la bataille en gardant la même et
quelques cadeaux
les gangs or on l'a justement
d'apprivoiser de volvo lutins
afin de me laisser tranquille là jusqu'à
maintenant je me suis débrouillé avec
mes lutins et je sais pas ce qui m'est
arrivé je ne sais pas pensé
c'est très ennuyeux très difficile là je
suis émerveillé d'être là ce soir j'ai
appris tant de choses
je savais un petit peu à cause de
theodore forstmann albert j'ai toujours
appelé théodore mais pourquoi la
librairie que de un homme qui était le
directeur d'un journal c'est important
que marianne grand écrivain ou la plus
tueur devant par méchanceté disait-il
non c'est parce que la première fois
quand je les rencontre et jeu j'avais
dit vivre dix minutes avec ce théodore
lie le support très plan voilà il ça
durait une malheureusement que 40 ans
alors bon ben
j'ai été tout de suite j'ai commencé
très tôt la musique pas exprès à trois
ans et demi je crois que je suis
musicienne je respire comme l'air la
musique c'est tout et puis j'étais
comédienne j'ai un complexe on en a pas
parlé ce soir j'ai toujours été très
petit et pas beaucoup grandi
c'est pour ça mais ça ne s'est pas faire
parce que j'aime me et quand j'étais à
l'odéon je pleurais parce que je ne
pouvais pas jouer autre chose que les
travestis à cause de ma taille ça a
commencé par le piano je peux pas faire
l'octave
alors c'est embêtant pour une pianiste
c'est pas possible et donc ça me
flanquer un complexe ne savais pas que
ça s'appelait comme ça puis la caille
après un genre ahmed 50 et quelques
poussières ça marche pas alors que
pouvez-vous être les petits gars ans
agaçant jusqu'à ce que j'ai mis à me
disent que les meilleurs parfums sont
dans les petits flacons
il est complexe et qui adore été très
grand j'ai appris que vous avez joué
avec jean gabin dans une sorte de drogue
qu'ils s'appelaient fle si votre
rencontre est tout à fait étonnant
n'allez pas me faire dire
et je vois qu'en juin
quand j'ai joué pour la première fois
des gadins il était mon fiancé et il
devait embrasser ou ce contact
et je n'avais jamais embrassé le garçon
encore et l'absence de la bouche sur la
bouche
jamais jamais embrassé deux garçons oui
avec passion depuis que la gt ans je
sais pas je vais avoir 18 ans ça n'avait
pas fait en vie avant si c'est ce que
vous voulez qu'on
vous étiez déjà les à broadway à
hollywood non c'est après un rebond et
d'après ce que j'avais lu dans les
livres
ça risquait de faire un certain effet
oui voilà et alors c'est ce baiser
devant un public avec un orchestre qui
allaient attaquer parce que c'était une
opérette je l'avait supplié de ne pas le
faire on a joué le père est un nom je
voudrais pas comment ça s'est terminé
et après je suis parti en amérique j'ai
vraiment eu beaucoup de chance beaucoup
de 8,1 extraordinaire j'ai sans fenêtres
j'ai dit tout à l'heure je ne savais pas
pensé je ne savais pas réfléchir 1 pour
qu'il nomme m'a vu parole
blanche tout d'un coup il a été
épouvanté qu'est ce qui a je lui ai dit
je pense il a dit arrête ça tout de
suite alors comment leur garantir mais
donc je ne sais pas pensé mais je
supportais
je sais pas dans les luttes à j'étais en
amérique jouer vous avez une sensibilité
théodore pensé lui mais vous avez une
sensibilité plus grande que la sienne
c'est pas
le petit conservatoire elle maniait de
s'occuper des autres chaque os oui c'est
vrai le dos de partager cette joie de la
musique sur mon rythme et ça ce refus
jure que c'est normal jusque lundi la
playa les gens qu'il ya c'est qu'on veut
mais je vais vivre le sait que vous fait
vos débuts avec du chopin devant francis
planté qui a recueilli les élèves de
show pas car il a des dix ans la mort
des taux non
mais moi j'adore que tiendra évidemment
alors qu'au talent grâce à théodore à
les connaître de nombreux écrivains on
va en parler et c'est alors tout le
monde tous vos amis dit bon vous épousez
théodore et toulouse à midi ça va durer
quelques semaines n'est impossible mais
on vous avait dit ça a duré quarante ans
oui c'est vrai mais je veux dire que ce
trader quand ils se croyaient tout de
suite après votre mariage ils nous
obligent à grossir oui parce que j'étais
maigre comme un coucou il ne tenait pas
debout j'avais beaucoup travaillé je
n'ai pas pris un service lui le tour de
france enfin je sais pas ce que j'ai
fait et il a dit mme emmené dans une
maison drogue pour en suisse en effet il
a dit il faut en mettre cinq kilos de
plus alors c'était atroce pas ce que
l'on me gaz est comme moi j'étais mais
j'ai fait dix morts se situe à 6 si
jeune et j'ai divorcé je divorce est
quittée cet homme c'est pas possible
qu'est ce que j'ai fait
au début comme je ne le connaissais pas
j'avais fait mettre 1 1 ce rouge et un
sévère dans l'appartement
pas c'est plus prudent
alors elle était actionnée par mois
sorte que le rouge et ennemi de mon côté
assez souvent il avait beau appuyer sur
le vert ça marchait pas mais je trouvais
que c'était bien comme ça puisque nous
ne connaissions pas mais lui était
intelligent - pas et j'avais peur de ses
amis justement et je ne voulais pas
l'ennuyer avec les miens je voyais pas
comment je ferais entre si vous voulez
malraux et maurice chevalier houda
comment ça se passerait alors le feu
rouge marchait retracement est passée
par là je devais assister une
conversation à huy de malheur de malraux
avec avec les odeurs et antan lontan un
book mais vous raconter ce qu'ils moi je
les imagine il parlait tous les deux en
même temps il parlait tous les deux en
même temps je sais pas 7 8 heures 10
heures de suite et cie se croiser ceux
ci beaucoup s'est passé en corrèze dans
la maison du facteur là où nous étions
pendant la guerre et ils se parlaient
ils marchaient
temps en temps je portais un sandwich
une banane quelque chose disons avoir
feint pas du tout et je ne sais pas
comment il se sait pour parler et a eu
l'impression d'assister à un match de
ping pong
sens et ils se croisent et se croiser
mais c'est trop n'y ait pas une
continuer par les tendances à la voie
côté délicieuse histoire comment vous
avez obligé malraux à faire une course à
vélo il a perdu lamentablement habré
avait plus un manet a gagné avec ça il
était une prétention avec son vélo sport
que si mais comment est ce que vous avez
demandé à malraux au fond qui prennent
la relève de jean nohain ou écrire des
textes parfaite et alors
la valeur celle là consterné elle était
très ennuyée il a essayé parce que
extrêmement gentil plein de bonne
volonté et j'ai tout de même extirper et
puis j'avais la funeste manie le facteur
m'avait acheté un piano un petit piano
droit et j'avais la fumée se manie de
l'uriné 1ère comme j'ai l'habitude de
serre pour que les poètes les paroliers
s'imprègne de ma musique je 11 et la
sortie un verre deux verres deux
véhicules et met sous les arbres d'été
sous les arbres divers et ça s'est
terminé là
et puis à vue de chansons avez vous
demandé à camus aussi d'écrire des biens
si vous êtes vraiment séduite par camus
oui mais
j'étais très jalouse je suis très
jalouse de nature je me dis alors aux
très jalouse de théodore j'étais jalouse
de camus j'adore la neige c'était
insupportable sanaga si à la fin alors
je vais essayer de voir plus près mais
qu'est ce qu'il a ce camus qui nous
prend mon théodore tout le temps était
insupportable
et puis j'ai succombé à camus parce
qu'on ne peut pas réussi à camus alors
on a recommencé les histoires de
chansons mais lui
m'apporter des textes malheureusement je
suis incapable de faire une musique sur
un texte lu raf toujours
par contre je fais ma musique d'abord
alors aujourd'hui j'ai le malheureux
camus comme pour les mots croisés à
mettre des mots sur ma petite musique
mais il a essayé de coupe mais c'est
vrai que vous êtes bien que jalousie
extraordinaire très méfiante mais quand
vous allez donner un concert à bruxelles
alors vous portez vos et peuvent
organiser sa surveillance si c'est pas
beau ce magnifique vous appauvrir nous
et chose mais que je trouve absolument
délicieux c'est que alors vous dites
parti et le laisser plus de trois jours
mme étaient intolérables insupportables
jalouse et vous dites là vous parler
aujourd'hui je le suis toujours emmanuel
berl est mort en 76 76 quand je trouve
sur cette tombe un petit bouquet
d'anémone que je n'ai pas déposé je suis
contente et agacé
c'est resté encore comme ça mais est ce
que vous étiez par exemple jalouse aussi
de pas